okay so you have to expect that a guy
who writes a book called together is
better is gonna say something about
Thanksgiving I could talk about turkey
and I go talk about stuffing and I could
talk about my mom's amazing carrot
souffle
we really should publish that recipe
because it's so good anyway
Thanksgiving our country has a lot to
give thanks for but also we were pretty
divided right now and I keep reading
articles and hearing people that are
actually worried about going to
Thanksgiving because they have a family
member who voted for the opposite
candidate that they voted for and people
are worried about the tension that's
going to be in the room believe it or
not in the newspaper there have even
been articles about how to have that
difficult conversation here's the thing
to remember and the thing that I think
is amazing that everybody's coming to
Thanksgiving like you're actually gonna
all show up at the table I hope that
most families are doing that and that
people aren't abandoning Thanksgiving
because we have different political
views
as I said before maybe it's just the
optimist to me I love the fact that
regardless of the fact lots of facts
that we have different political views
that we're gonna come to the table as a
family to give thanks for being a family
and that's really what comes first and I
think we should let the Thanksgiving
table be the metaphor for what we need
to do for the future we are Americans
we're human beings
we come to our country we come to the
Thanksgiving table even when things are
bad for us things are pretty good in
America we're relatively safe we're
relatively happy like things are
relatively good and we have a lot to be
grateful for and if we come together and
instead of in dining each other and
pointing fingers and blaming each other
and say thanks to each other and maybe
had some empathy for where people are
coming from the stresses that they have
in their lives then maybe we'll all feel
a little bit better about asking each
other for help and here's one
I've learned together really is better
and so now for me to say thank you to
you I am fully aware that I get to do
what I do and I get to do stuff like
this because of all the wonderful people
who stand shoulder-to-shoulder with me
who believe in this brighter future this
better world who believe in things like
leaders eating last who believe in
things like starting with Y who believe
in things like together is better and
I'm so grateful to all of you and I feel
just immense gratitude that we actually
are changing our world for the better
because we stand arm and arm shoulder to
shoulder regardless of who we voted for
because we believe in the same vision of
the world a world in which the vast
majority of us wake up every single
morning inspired to go to work feel safe
when we're there and returned home
fulfilled at the end of the day wishing
everyone a fantastic Thanksgiving